[موسيقى]
في قاعده اسمها رول اف 3
تقدر تعيش ثلاث ساعات بدون ماوى ثلاث ايام
بدون مويه ثلاث اسابيع بدون اكل احنا
البشر اول شيء يجينا نخاف نتوترات ابغاك
ابغاك لا لا انت تبغى ماوى حتى ما قالوا
النار عادي اهم شيء الماوى بعدين تلقى
المويه تلاكن تقدر تعيش ثلاثه ايام بدون
مويه يا جماعه بعدين ثلاث اسابيع بدون اكل
هذه من اهم القواعد اللي اتبعها في البقاء
قيد الحياه قررت ارجع لان شكلها بتمطر هنا
صافيه هذيك جايه
هو تحدي لما كنت لحالي في الجزيره كان
النار لانه نزل عليه المطر
وبعدين قلت خليني اكسر حاجز الخوف عندي
لانه النار هي ونيسها تعتبر نار صديقه لك
في الاماكن هذه
سلبيه زي النمل اللي جاء في وجهي
النمل وانا نايم
في وجهي شوي اعطاني شويه ميك اب هذه لو
تتشب بالنار كانت دخان يعني ابعد عني
الحشرات هذي
[موسيقى]
يا رب رزقك طبعا الاكل اللي موجود عندك
انت لازم تعيش تتعايش معاه الاكل اللي
موجود الاغلب الحال اللي هو السمك
فالمفروض ان واحد يروح يحاول يصيد سمك
حاولت اصيد سمك حاولت تصيد سمك ثلاثه ايام
ربما وفقني فيها
فاضطريت اني اكل بعض الشغلات الثانيه زي
عندك الفاصوليا حصلت فاصوليا كذا نيه
تاكلها طيبه البقاء على قيد الحياه بسم
الله عند بيتي
فاصوليا الجوز الهند انت وحظك وحده سيئه
وحده كويسه يلا
فهذه الشغلات اللي حاولت اني اكلها بكره
ان شاء الله يوم جديد لان ظلمه
على الف خير يا رب
[موسيقى]